let's do this and we're going to try to
do it remember all answers in the form
of a question first topic this rookie
quarterback will have the most
impressive 2021 season sharing you're up
first
who is mike jones mike because i think
the 49ers are going to take mack jones i
think mac jones is ready to play in the
nfl i think he is going to be the 49ers
starter and they have the best team when
you look at the team they were in super
bowl two years ago they're getting all
those guys back including nick bosa
they're they're going to be healthy
going into 2021 they hope uh but but
they'll get a ton of guys back i just
think he's going to the best team of
those top three guys and i think the
49ers have a chance to be really really
good this year
i'm going to say who is trevor lawrence
he's kind of been forgotten in all this
talk about mac jones and zach wilson and
where's justin feels going to go and
what about trey lance
trevor lawrence is the guy he's the he's
the the ultra five star blue chip best
prospect since andrew luck and
everything they've been doing in
jacksonville is geared toward making it
work for him and i think we're so
conditioned to think the jaguars are the
jaguars like the browns or the browns i
i think that we're gonna be surprised by
what lawrence does because we're just
focused on
all these other guys and all these other
teams and the bar is pretty low in the
afc south relative to some of the other
divisions especially in the afc i think
trevor lawrence is going to give us a
season and a performance that we aren't
really expecting because we just have
kind of taken for granted that you know
this guy's going to show up and be a
starter and we haven't understood how
good he potentially can be next topic
the nfl team that missed the playoffs
last year
that will make it well let me try i
screwed that up this nfl team that
missed the playoffs last year will make
it in 2021.
who are the 49ers i'm staying with that
same theme mike because again this is a
team that was just in the super bowl two
years ago i think they're ready to
rebound i know that division is really
really good and the cardinals could be
that team this year i understand that
and i had them on my list of teams that
i thought could get there but that
division
is really good but i think the 49ers are
going to rebound and go back to the
playoffs this season mike
this one's easy for me and i'm not being
a partisan here i'm not having
flashbacks to 1975 my chuck foreman
hoodie or whatever the case may be
it's it's it's math it's hashtag
analytics this is the year the vikings
get to the playoffs because it's every
other year under mike zimmer
odd-numbered year they get there
even-numbered year they don't get there
it's an odd-numbered year they get there
and uh with the defense better couldn't
have been much worse than it was last
year with fans present for home games
i i still worry about the left tackle
position they got to replace rally reef
somehow but justin jefferson was awesome
last year
dalvin cook if he's healthy if he's not
the guy alexander madison i think the
vikings will be good enough to at least
get the eighth seed so i think the
vikings is a team that missed it last
year and easily could have made it with
one game that went their way here or
there but didn't didn't happen this year
i think it will all right next topic
this player will have the best bounce
back season in 2021 shireen
i think the key phrase here is bounce
back instead of comeback player of the
year because we all know that my
definition of comeback player of the
year is it can't be because you suck the
year before i hope i can say suck don't
talk because
because you claimed good because you
weren't good the year before but i'm
going to say it's really funny
i'm going to say who is nick bosa
because i god that's all 49ers i just
realized but dak prescott saquon barkley
christian mccaffrey carson wentz there's
a ton of guys i think that really can
bounce back this year but i'm going to
stick with the 49 hours ago nick boson
because i think he's really really good
at what he does and i think he could
have a chance to win defensive player of
the year this year mike yeah and look
there's a long list of guys we can point
to and say they were injured the injury
derailed their season last year
christian mccaffrey michael thomas he
was never the same guy after missing all
that time with the ankle
i i i want to go with matthew stafford
because he he's always injured to some
degree or another but he always plays
and he'll probably be banged up to some
degree or another with the rams but will
still play but this new scenery for him
getting out of detroit he will have
a much better year than he had last year
whether it's good enough to actually get
to the playoffs and win a playoff game
that remains to be seen he's never won a
playoff game in his career and i think
he's only been there three times but i
think the rams will make the playoffs
and we get to see matthew stafford
operating potentially at a level we've
never seen before with sean mcvay
rejuvenated mcveigh rejuvenated stafford
and not because of injury but because of
performance and supporting cast and
culture potentially in detroit last year
we didn't see the best of matthew
staffordshire
yeah we didn't mike and that's a really
good choice based on what he did in
detroit and his chance to do even more
with the rams with the better cast
around him and i think christian
mccaffrey is going to have a great year
this year too if he can stay healthy and
he stayed healthy every year in his
career except this year so so there's no
reason to think he won't be healthy in
2021 and rebound and you know you look
at what he did in the all-pro season in
in 2019 i think he could have a big
bounce back here too
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports